[Musique]
avez-vous de la difficulté à vous y
retrouver face à l'abondance d'études
sur l'alimentation
en tout cas vous êtes nombreux à nous
écrire pour nous demander des
éclaircissements sur ce type d'étude
alors comment bien interpréter une
nouvelle qui porte sur l'alimentation
prenons l'exemple du chocolat si la
saint valentin après tout catherine on
reçoit énormément de courriels ou
décrypteurs à toutes les semaines sur
les études qui portent sur
l'alimentation
prenons l'exemple du chocolat qui
auraient des vertus en ce qui a trait à
la pression artérielle et qu'on fait que
ce genre d'études locaux marquent elles
grille d'analysé doit avoir déjà dans
l'article un point qu'on va lire dans
les médias on va avoir un titre
accrocheur le choco leur abaisse la
tension artérielle
ça fait plaisir oui mais quand on lit
l'article
on comprend que finalement on a utilisé
une composante souvent c'est les
antioxydants dans le cacao
donc là on parle pas de chocolat on
parle de poudre de cacao qui fait partie
de la composition du chocolat convoi
mélange évidemment avec du beurre de
cacao du sucre parfois d'autres
ingrédients selon la qualité du jeu
comme donc des gens mais on parle pas de
la même chose
deuxième chose clubic personnes
idéalement face à fish option wifi seul
échantillon donc idéalement en vue ce
soir sur le modèle humain exception à
une échantillon substantielle donc des
fois on va voir sur 50 personnes comme
beaucoup cinq ans et la durée
est-ce que c'est sur deux semaines un an
deux ans trois ans 50 souvent dans les
études on va nommer les résultats comme
étant significativement probable mais un
exemple d'études de jeu
nu c'était deux points pour la tension
ce steeple qui est très peu une
distinction importante catherine si le
contexte dans lequel l'étude a été fait
en laboratoire c'est pas comme dans la
vraie vie
exactement donc on voyait qui dit
justement une composante très précises
pour avoir un effet précis mais la
réalité dans le cas du chocolat par
exemple on ne mange pas de la poudre de
chocolat ou de la poudre de cacao pardon
mais bien du chocolat bien souvent on
préfère le chocolat au lait donc c'est
très correct de manger du chocolat au
lait mais c'est pas la même réalité que
dans les tours donc souvent on parle
laboratoire et on extrapole à la vie
puis il ya plein de d'habitude de mode
de vie qui vont avoir un impact beaucoup
plus grand sur la santé que le carré de
chocolat qu'on fonctionne ou non
souvent on va avoir souvent c'est au bas
de l'article on va avoir une élément de
nuance la part des chercheurs qui vont
direct oui on est arrivés ces résultats
là c'est intéressant mais la réalité ce
qu'on ne peut pas conclure ou avancer
quelques conclusions que c'est toi donc
première étape faut aller au delà du
titre
ensuite faut s'attarder à l'article aux
nuances au détail
si l'article en contient là on se méfie
désertique qui disent pas grand chose
mais ensuite qu'il finance finance
l'étude sont exactement retrouvant la
source de financement de l'article on
voit à la fin juste avant les références
qui habituellement c'est là qu'on va
trouver l'information donc dans le cas
du chocolat ça pourrait être financée
par un fabricant de chocolat ça veut pas
dire que les résultats sont faux mais ça
peut vouloir dire que la méthodologie a
été dirigée pour favoriser l'industrie
en question mais on parle de chocolat
depuis le début catherine faut bien
comprendre que cette même recette l'on
peut l'appliquer à l'ensemble des nuits
en fait ça s'est vraiment avoir le
réflexe de lire le titre d'aller voir
c'est quoi l'étude réellement piqué
quelle a été la méthodologie
le modèle l'échantillon la durée
idéalement la source de financement et
quel a été le résultat puisqu'elle est
la nuance que les chercheurs rapportent
l'idée c'est de d'avoir la bonne
information
est ce que ça veut dire qu'on ne mange
plus de chocolat bien sûr que non il
faudrait pas maintenant il faut les
manger pour les bonnes raisons
c'est sur la notion de plaisir voilà
c'est très important